there's nothing technically stopping me
buying a ps4 I just like to make my my
big technical purchases and steps my
last one was a big TV so I guess next on
the list is a ps4 I've borrowed one a
couple of times from work and I know
that I love it so it's definitely coming
next I picked up a ps4 it launched and I
wouldn't say I play it every day it's
probably my most used home console I'm
definitely more of a PC gamer and
honestly just because I kind of have a
longer commute and because I prefer the
games I spend more time on my 3ds but
it's a definite really strong number 3 I
do know what to bring a ps4 the main
platform I play I would say 90 to 95% of
my games long is PC it's another one of
the reasons I haven't picked up a
Playstation 4
because multi plot is everything there
are few and far between exclusives that
I'm going out of my way for at the
moment and if it's on PC and PlayStation
4 and Xbox I'm gonna play it on PC I've
had it sent so since launch typically
when it comes to consoles I get launch
consoles and that's no exception i
pre-ordered a Wii U i pre-ordered an
Xbox one and i pre-ordered a Playstation
4 and at this stage the Xbox one is
usually my go-to machine for just
general media like if I want to watch
Netflix or Hulu I usually use the Xbox
one for that and if I want to play games
usually it's the PlayStation 4 nowadays
started off mostly the Netflix machine
and it's only really recently that I
felt that the games have really
definitely justified my purchase it took
a while but we finally got there I think
maybe the tide turned when medgar saw
Ground zeroes came out because I really
enjoyed playing that and I got to
download it and then just play it on the
system and I was wanted to sort of pick
up and play things so I was more
encouraged to turn on my ps4 and one of
my favorite games came out this year
transistor was an exclusive for it or at
least console exclusive and I adore
playing that as well so I kind of got me
back into the
and the rhythm of turning on my
playstation personally my favorite thing
about having a ps4 is it seems like
everyone else has fun and I've never had
something like that before because last
generation I was on PlayStation 3 anyone
I met and all my friends here at games
what like everyone had an Xbox 360 so
I've never really played online with
anyone or at least anyone that I knew
and then PlayStation 4 comes along and
it took a little while but then a game
like destiny came along and everyone
played on ps4 together and that was just
this new experience for me that I've
never had in the last generation the
best thing about owning a ps4 is all the
670 first party games and now it sounds
fanboys but I've been like a sunni a
nintendo guy for a while and yeah soon
he's always had really good exclusive
like a lost boss and infamous and all
that kind of stuff
I think multi-platform is better with
Sony so I used to use a xbox 360 because
everything just worked I didn't have to
have to fight it whereas I always felt I
was kind of fighting my ps3 but ps4 you
know I'm playing with friends online is
a complete breeze the controller is just
really comfortable to use you can plug
your headphones in it the light even
like in some games it'll be lit up when
you're visible and off when you're in
darkness and it's lost just little
things that I'm using it and I'm
thinking huh that's really good or it's
things you don't even notice because
it's so slick and user-friendly so
that's the that's the biggest thing when
I've taken one home it's just been so
easy and it's just let me play the games
I'm not to fly anything they say that
like you know truly great pieces of
design you don't really notice because
things just work and I feel that way
quite strongly about the PlayStation 4
like I just I love the interface it's
very slick it's very clean I like that I
can just you know put a game in and the
install doesn't take forever and I can
just stop playing so I guess the best
thing about having a ps4 is not having
to use an Xbox one and I know I'm gonna
get a lot of flack for that but the
whole experience is just so much nicer
you turn it on it's got this really
soothing lovely music and then you push
a button then you're in
it's very easy it's very simple if I
want to change settings it's really easy
the Xbox one UI is still not quite there
yet and not having to deal with that is
one of the best things they're quite
expensive at the moment and all the
games that I want to play on them we
have in the office just over here so
I've kind of actually played through
everything that's out in the office and
I don't need to go home and play them
again yes see I think the first year of
the PlayStation 4 has been a little bit
underwhelming there hasn't really been a
major must-have game for the system
there's been a few re-releases and
remasters but there's nothing really
that's there on it that makes me want to
use the machine all the time and there's
nothing I like if one of my friends
asked me you know should I buy a
Playstation 4 really at the moment I
would say hold on to your money because
I don't think there's there's one single
reason why you should vote it's a tough
question to decide whether one platform
serves your needs because your needs are
different so my needs are largely
multiplayer I like to play with my
friends and a lot of people have adopted
the ps4 especially for things like
destiny and I love a little of going
home to play you know in a big fire team
with with my best friends but in terms
of being able to have access to a lot of
games a big library of games at great
value than the PC is is still my
platform of choice but so few with the
exception of hearthstone so few people
are playing on PC that I know so I think
in terms of what I want out of a console
the ps4 is it